sky is a company have pledged to remove
all of their single-use plastics from
business operations by the year 2020 and
obviously us a Team Sky are getting
getting fully behind sky in doing that
and and we want to try and help raise as
much awareness for the project as
possible yeah and I know it's part of
that awareness is you're gonna wear a
special Tour de France shirt certainly
to launch it all with recycled plastic
in it is that one of them beside you can
we have a look that's it exactly so this
is going to be what we're what we're
going to use on this year's Tour de
France which is the sky ocean rescue
jersey and on the on the back we've got
a got an auger on the back but I think
more importantly obviously is is the
message where we're looking to raise
through the the sky ocean rescue I mean
it just is staggering to hear figures
like how much plastic goes into the
ocean every year I mean we've got eight
million tonnes of plastic that goes into
all the seas every year and so this is a
huge campaign to try and try and reduce
that number as much as possible yeah and
the team itself and its supply chain
must get through quite a lot of
single-use plastic so and I'm thinking
let's talk about shirts again you know
they come in plastic bags when the fans
buy them how will you address things
like that and of course let me throw in
as well and when we see you riding in
these grand tours you throw away yeah
plastic bottles what happens to them sky
as a business have made this pledge to
try and remove all the single-use
plastics by 2020 but even even us at
Team Sky working with all of our
partners we're gonna try and reduce as
much as possible the the use of
single-use plastics that that we have in
the team and there are obviously parts
of of our job as bike races where we
have to drop our drop our bottles or
certain litter and different points but
but part of that process for us will be
making sure there are people behind the
scenes who could who can go along and
dispose of all those plastics properly
you are now the hold are one of the very
few holders of three consecutive Grand
Tour titles the Tour de France the
wealth spaniel and the Giro d'Italia how
does that feel to be part of that
pantheon of greats it's it's I mean I'm
still it's still sinking in if I'm
honest I mean it's just this is there's
no greater goal in in our sport to to be
the current leader of all the three
Grand Tours so I mean it's just it's an
incredible feeling and an incredible
position to be in
and Chris do you think you'll be allowed
to attempt to make it four in a row
there is some suggestion that the
organizers of the Tour de France might
not let you in because of this
investigation into your high levels of
salbutamol in Spain last year yeah I
mean I'm obviously fully fully confident
that there's been no wrongdoing and we
were in the middle of a process now to
be able to demonstrate that that I have
done nothing wrong so hopefully
hopefully that will be sorted out as
soon as possible and ideally before the
Tour de France but you must have been
disheartened a little bit when we heard
there from cycling's governing body the
UCI saying that there's a 50% chance
that it will be sorted out by the time
of the Tour de France yes well I mean
this the whole the whole process has
been has been laid out by the UCI and
we're we're following basically their
their guidelines in getting to the
bottom of this I mean just four people
haven't been following it Chris what
exactly happened then in Spain you've
got exercised induced asthma you've got
one of those in hailers did you just
perhaps overuse it a bit
no not at all I mean you're allowed to
take up to 16 inhalations of of your
inhaler a day and I know for sure that I
didn't take anywhere near 16 inhalations
so yeah I mean this this whole process
you have to remember was was meant to
have being a confidential process
because the facts are not not yet
established but once once we get to the
end of that process we'd be able to
share all that information with with
people and hopefully that would that
will give people a lot more confidence
about what what has and what certainly
hasn't happened here yeah well best of
luck with that process last question and
I suppose it's quite current and I know
it's been discussed quite a lot within
the world of cycling and this is the
issue and it's not trivial of podium
girls of those very beautiful models
that stand on the podium at the end of
each stage we saw them in the Giro
d'Italia some discussion that the Tour
de France might stop that practice how
do you feel after you've won a stage do
you feel comfortable when that happens
to you or do you feel like a little kind
of you know what's going on here quite
frankly I mean it's it's not for us as
bike riders to decide I mean different
sports I mean you have to look at
motorsport they're there they're really
big into that kind of thing obviously
cycling some some events are for summer
against it and to be honest it's not
really something I spend a lot of time
thinking about I go to the race I do it
if if they're there they're there if
they're not they're not it's not it
doesn't it doesn't doesn't change how I
approach a race